Une méditation guidée détaillée Instructions sur la manière de pratiquer Vipassana Bhavana, la méditation de la vision intérieure telle qu'elle a été enseignée par le Mahasi Sayado de Birmanie.
Il s'agit dans un premier temps d'établir le corps dans une posture de méditation.
Certaines personnes s'asseillent sur une chaise, d'autres utilisent un petit tabouret, mais la position habituelle est de s'asseoir sur un coussin au sol avec les jambes croisées.
Les mains reposent l'une sur l'autre au niveau du giron, de préférence la main gauche sur la main droite.
Peu importe la position adoptée, le plus important est qu'elle soit confortable.
Assurez-vous que la colonne vertébrale est droite, tout en gardant sa courbure naturelle.
Il est conseillé de ne pas s'appuyer sur le dossier car cela peut induire le sommeil.
Maintenant, imaginez une ficelle de marionnette parcourant la colonne vertébrale depuis sa base jusqu'au sommet de la tête, vous étirant doucement vers le haut, créant de l'espace entre les vertèbres ainsi qu'une sensation d'étirement et de légèreté.
Une sensation d'énergie parcourt la colonne sans tension ni raideur.
La tête repose en équilibre au sommet de la colonne.
Le reste du corps se détend à partir de cet axe central.
A ce stade nous pouvons utiliser des exercices simples pour nous aider à mieux nous détendre.
Premièrement, nous allons voir si nous pouvons nous détendre en suggérant simplement à nos muscles de se relâcher.
Commencez au sommet de la tête et déplacez la tension dans chaque partie du corps en descendant et en relaxant les muscles du mieux que vous pouvez.
Donc, le sommet de la tête.
Descendez vers le front.
Les yeux sont doucement fermés.
Les joues.
Les mâchoires.
Les lèvres sont jointes, les dents ne se touchent pas.
Si les dents sont serrées, cela crée des tensions dans les mâchoires.
la nuque, les épaules, les bras, les mains.
Ressentez tout le corps devenir léger ou parfois lourd au fur et à mesure que les tensions s'en vont.
Maintenant, revenez à la cage thoracique.
Détendez-la.
Descendez le long du corps, l'abdomen, l'estomac, détendez-les du mieux que vous pouvez, le dos, les fesses.
Pour terminer, ressentez juste vos jambes lourdes sur le sol.
Les tensions superficielles devraient maintenant être relâchées, du moins en partie.
Mais il se peut que nous ressentions un niveau de tension plus profond, plus familier, et par conséquent difficile à détendre par un acte de volonté mentale.
Nous pouvons alors utiliser une deuxième technique qui repose sur la contraction musculaire.
Dans les zones où vous ressentez une tension, contractez les muscles autant que vous pouvez avant de les relâcher lentement.
Ceci est particulièrement efficace avec les tensions du visage.
Contractez les muscles du visage autant que possible.
Maintenez la contraction.
Relâchez.
Encore une fois.
Contractez les muscles du visage.
Maintenez.
Relâchez.
Cela marche également avec les tensions dans la nuque et les épaules.
Contractez toute cette zone en remontant les épaules.
Maintenez la contraction et relâchez lentement.
Encore une fois, contractez la zone de la nuque et des épaules.
Maintenez, relâchez lentement.
La troisième technique efficace pour relâcher les tensions ressenties au niveau de la poitrine, tout en ayant également un effet bénéfique sur l'ensemble du corps et la respiration contrôlée.
Prenez une longue et profonde inspiration.
Remplissez complètement les poumons.
Gardez les poumons pleins aussi longtemps que confortable.
Puis laissez la cage thoracique retomber rapidement en expirant tout l'air.
Attendez ensuite que l'inspiration suivante se manifeste naturellement, afin d'éviter l'hyperventilation.
Alors prenons maintenant une profonde inspiration.
Retenez-la.
Relâchez.
Encore une fois, inspirez profondément, retenez l'air, relâchez.
Vous pouvez répéter cet exercice autant de fois que nécessaire, mais maintenant vous avez probablement développé un état de relaxation et de détente relativement profond.
Nous sommes maintenant dans une posture très favorable à la méditation.
La colonne est dynamisée sans être tendue.
Le reste du corps est détendu comme s'il pendait à partir de cette colonne centrale qu'est la colonne vertébrale.
La tête doucement en équilibre à son sommet.
symbolise l'équilibre d'un corps détendu et alerte.
Maintenant essayez de ressentir pendant quelques instants la posture dans son ensemble et de prendre conscience de reconnaître les qualités d'énergie alerte et de détente calme qui sont présentes dans le corps.
Maintenant, il nous faut développer le même état d'attention détendue et de calme énergique dans l'esprit, après l'avoir développé dans le corps.
Et pour cela, nous utilisons la respiration.
Placez votre attention au niveau de l'abdomen et ressentez comme il se soulève et s'abaisse au rythme de la respiration naturelle.
Il ne s'agit pas d'une technique de respiration.
On ne doit pas modifier ou interférer avec la respiration.
Juste la laisser telle qu'elle est.
Si vous avez des difficultés à percevoir la respiration au niveau de l'abdomen, voyez si vous pouvez ressentir la poitrine se soulever puis s'abaisser.
Et sinon, vous pouvez également utiliser le contact de la respiration à l'entrée des narines.
Mais, d'après la technique du Mahasi Sayado, il est préférable d'utiliser l'abdomen.
Voyez ce qui vous convient le mieux.
Quel que soit l'endroit que vous ayez choisi, demeurez-y.
C'est votre objet de méditation de référence, votre ancrage.
Cela signifie que vous utilisez cet endroit pour établir une attention calme et alerte.
Si vous déplacez l'attention d'un endroit à l'autre, par exemple des narines à l'abdomen, cela diminue votre aptitude à développer le calme et la concentration, la tension.
Autrement dit, vous seriez moins capable d'observer avec une attention calme et alerte sans que l'esprit s'échappe.
Si vous observez le processus de la respiration au niveau de l'abdomen ou de la poitrine, ressentez comment ceci se soulève et s'abaisse.
et utiliser un mot de notation pour calmer le processus de la pensée.
Donc, sur l'inspiration, prononcer intérieurement « se soulever, se soulever » et sur l'expiration, prononcer intérieurement « s'abaisser, s'abaisser ».
Après l'expiration, l'inspiration apparaît parfois immédiatement sans aucune pause.
Mais au fur et à mesure que vous vous détendez, une pause apparaîtra.
Il se peut aussi qu'il y ait une pause avant l'inspiration du début.
Pendant la pause, il y a le risque que l'esprit s'évade dans les pensées et les fantaisies.
Pour éviter cela, nous choisissons un point de contact.
Ça peut être le ressenti des mains sur les cuisses, le contact des jambes sur le sol.
Choisissez ce qui est le plus facile, le plus évident.
Au moment où vous ressentez l'abdomen ou la poitrine se soulever à l'inspiration,
Ressentez les sensations, observez-les de près et dirigez votre attention directement sur elles en notant « se soulever, se soulever ».
De la même manière, lorsque vous ressentez l'abdomen ou la poitrine s'abaisser à l'expiration,
Soyez conscient du ressenti, des sensations provoquées par le mouvement.
Observez-les attentivement et prononcez intérieurement « s'abaisser, s'abaisser ».
S'il y a une pause avant l'inspiration, utilisez le point de contact.
et prononcer intérieurement toucher, toucher.
Assurez-vous de revenir immédiatement au ventre ou à la poitrine au moment de l'inspiration suivante.
Le processus est le même si vous vous concentrez sur les narines.
Sauf que dans ce cas, il faut plutôt utiliser les mots suivants.
Inspire, inspire.
Expire, expire.
Et dans ce cas-là, on fait attention aux sensations à l'entrée des narines au niveau de la lèvre supérieure.
Là où le passage de l'air est ressenti avec le plus d'acuité.
Peu importe le nombre de fois où vous utilisez le petit mot de note mentale.
Il se peut qu'une seule fois suffise.
Le plus important, c'est d'être attentif aux ressentis et aux sensations.
Le mot lui-même a peu d'importance.
C'est juste une manière simple et efficace d'empêcher l'esprit de vagabonder,
et de garder notre attention sur l'objet d'attention.
Ce à quoi nous devons être attentifs, ce sont les sensations provoquées par le processus de la respiration.
Même en pratiquant ainsi, il se peut que l'esprit vagabonde dans des pensées ou des fantaisies.
Dès que vous sortez de votre rêverie, notez simplement ce que l'esprit est en train de faire.
Pensez, pensez, rêvez, rêvez, planifiez, planifiez, s'inquiétez, s'inquiétez, etc.
Prononcer juste deux fois le mot suffit.
La première fois c'est pour remarquer ce qui est en train de se passer.
Et la deuxième pour vraiment reconnaître ce dans quoi l'esprit s'est fait prendre.
Une fois que vous avez prononcé ces deux mots et été attentif, ramenez avec détermination votre attention sur l'observation des sensations provoquées par la respiration.
Ne faites pas cela avec brusquerie, brutalité ou en employant la force.
Entraîner l'esprit, c'est un peu comme apprendre un jeune chiot à s'asseoir.
A chaque fois qu'il se lève, on le fait rasseoir gentiment, mais avec fermeté.
Si on se fâche et qu'on le frappe, il aura juste envie de partir en courant.
Donc c'est pareil pour notre esprit, gentillesse et fermeté, le ramener avec gentillesse, douceur, fermeté, détermination.
Pratiquons maintenant cette méditation de la respiration pendant quelques instants en observant et en notant toutes les sensations.
Se soulever, se soulever, s'abaisser, s'abaisser, toucher, toucher.
Si votre esprit vagabonde, notez ce qu'il est en train de faire.
Rêver, penser, s'inquiéter, etc. Et ramenez-le doucement et fermement à la méditation, à la respiration.
Si vous avez envie de dormir, mettez plus d'énergie dans la colonne vertébrale.
Notre posture est érigée sans être tendue.
Dans cette deuxième partie de la méditation, on essaie d'établir une attention calme et stable.
Il est normal de consacrer dix bonnes minutes à cette pratique, jusqu'à ce que l'esprit devienne relativement calme
du moins jusqu'à ce que le niveau d'agitation le plus grossier ait disparu et que nous puissions observer l'objet, dans ce cas la respiration, de manière relativement constante.
Nous utilisons la respiration car c'est un ressenti neutre, ni excitant, ni déprimant.
Ressentez le mouvement calme et doux de la respiration.
un peu comme le mouvement d'une vague.
Ressentez les sensations de la respiration neutre et plaisante.
Ceci conduit l'esprit dans un silence qui lui permet de développer une attention stable.
Ce type de concentration est différent de la concentration que nous obtenons lorsque nous faisons quelque chose d'absorbant comme regarder un film ou faire un travail minutieux.
Cette concentration-là dépend de la stimulation.
Mais l'attention dont nous avons besoin pour la pratique spirituelle apparaît lorsque l'esprit est calme et tranquille.
Lorsque nous avons établi un état d'esprit centré et focalisé, nous découvrons qu'une autre faculté se développe, notre intelligence intuitive, Panya.
Parfois, lorsque vous essayez d'écouter la radio, les interférences sont si fortes qu'il est difficile d'entendre exactement ce qui est dit.
Une fois que les grésillements ont disparu, tout devient clair.
Ces grésillements correspondent dans la méditation au mental qui pense, imagine, planifie.
Dès que le mental est calmé, l'intelligence intuitive peut investiguer et voir plus clairement ce qui se passe à l'intérieur.
voir plus clairement ce qui se passe à l'intérieur.
Donc notre tâche consiste maintenant à établir cette attention focalisée, stable, animée par l'intelligence Satipanya, non seulement sur la respiration, mais sur tout ce qui entre dans notre champ de conscience.
Donc ouvrir cette attention à tout ce qui entre dans le champ de conscience.
On peut se référer au cas de l'observateur des oiseaux.
Les observateurs d'oiseaux sont assis dans un observatoire.
Ils sont cachés et observent les oiseaux sans être aperçus d'eux.
De cette manière, les oiseaux ne sont pas perturbés.
Il est alors possible d'observer leur comportement habituel de façon objective.
Tout ce que nous savons sur la manière dont les oiseaux se nourrissent,
font leur nid, se reproduisent, etc., provient juste de l'observation qui a été faite d'eux, du simple fait de les avoir regardés.
De la même manière, l'aptitude à être simplement observateur, intéressé par la découverte de notre vraie nature, de la vraie nature de notre corps, de notre esprit,
et de notre cœur.
Voilà la clé de la pratique spirituelle.
Cette capacité à être un observateur attentif et bienveillant.
Cette observation n'est pas une quête de quelque chose.
Nous ne cherchons rien.
Nous sommes de simples observateurs
qui regardons sans intervenir tout ce qui apparaît dans le champ de conscience.
Juste regarder, ressentir, accueillir, expérimenter tout ce qui se manifeste ici et maintenant, au moment où cela se produit, de la manière dont cela se produit.
sans ajouter aucune pensée sur ce qui se passe, aucun commentaire, aucun jugement.
Après avoir établi cette attention stable sur la respiration, nous ouvrons le champ de conscience.
Si un son est entendu, notre attention se tourne vers lui immédiatement.
Et l'on utilise un petit mot de note mentale.
Entendre.
Nous essayons de percevoir la qualité du son au niveau du tympan lui-même.
De cette manière, nous empêchons l'esprit de s'envoler vers l'objet.
qui alors peut-être par exemple le gazouillis d'un oiseau, le son d'une voiture qui passe.
Donc l'objectif c'est d'empêcher l'esprit de construire toute une suite de pensées, de concepts et d'imagination autour de l'objet entendu.
Il en est de même avec les odeurs.
Dans ces cas-là, nous disons intérieurement « sentir ».
Et nous mettons notre attention au niveau des narines et dans les narines elles-mêmes.
Nous faisons la même chose avec n'importe quelle sensation dans le corps.
Par exemple, une démangeaison, un fourmillement, un picotement, la sensation des contacts des jambes sur le sol.
On note simplement ce qu'on constate.
Démanger, démanger, lourdeur, lourdeur, picotement, picotement.
tout en maintenant l'attention à l'endroit même où les sensations sont ressenties.
Et on plonge notre attention dans la sensation.
Pour en avoir une vision le plus précise, la plus intime possible, la plus exacte, la plus déconceptualisée possible.
D'autres sensations peuvent apparaître dans le corps, comme la chaleur, le froid, la lourdeur, la légèreté, toutes sortes de ressentis inconfortables ou plaisants.
Et puis il y a en général de l'inconfort lié à la posture, par exemple des douleurs dans les genoux.
On peut dans ce cas-là employer un mot spécifique, intérieurement comme « douleur »,
chaleur, froid, tiraillement.
Si on ne sait pas quel mot employer, peu importe, on peut employer un mot général comme sensation.
Cela convient très bien aussi.
Et il est important de ne pas réagir à ces sensations, à moins que celles-ci soient tellement douloureuses qu'elles sont intolérables.
Le fait d'utiliser un petit mot de notation mentale est une technique que nous utilisons pour contrôler la faculté de penser, afin de maintenir une attention stable sur l'objet d'attention.
Mais l'attention elle-même se loge dans les sensations observées.
Et puis, il peut y avoir des sensations dans le corps provoquées par des états d'esprit ou des émotions, des énergies.
Certaines sont déplaisantes comme la peur, la dépression, la culpabilité.
D'autres sont plaisantes comme l'excitation, la joie, l'amour.
Alors nous pouvons utiliser des mots spécifiques comme culpabilité, joie, excitation, peur.
L'important c'est de ressentir pleinement dans le corps l'état d'esprit ou l'émotion.
Parfois, certaines de nos sensations corporelles, nous pensons qu'elles sont causées par une émotion.
Par exemple, qu'une douleur à l'estomac est le résultat de l'anxiété.
Il n'est pas nécessaire d'identifier ou d'analyser ces ressentis comme étant le résultat d'une émotion, d'une énergie ou d'un état mental.
Il suffit juste de noter et observer ces sensations telles que vous les ressentez.
Tension, tension, tension.
Nausées, nausées, etc. Et puis il y a aussi des pensées et des images qui peuvent venir.
Notez-les juste comme elles sont, intérieurement.
Pensées, pensées, images, images, et elles disparaîtront.
Si vous n'utilisez pas ce petit mot de notation, elle risque, ces pensées, de vous emmener dans une rêverie éveillée qui peut parfois durer toute la durée de la méditation.
Soyez particulièrement attentifs à l'esprit qui juge.
C'est mal, c'est bien, c'est super, c'est terrible, etc. N'essayez pas de changer, de modifier ou d'interférer ce type de pensée.
Reconnaissez-les simplement pour ce qu'elles sont.
Jugement, jugement.
Nous ne sommes pas des spectateurs qui s'impliquent dans le jeu de l'esprit, en soutenant telle pensée plutôt que telle autre.
Au contraire, nous adoptons la position de l'observateur.
pas celle du joueur, un observateur objectif et bienveillant.
On permet juste au jeu de l'esprit de se déployer juste là, sous notre regard.
A chaque instant, nous essayons de maintenir cette distance, ce détachement par rapport à ce qui est en train de se passer dans le corps, l'esprit et le cœur, cette désidentification.
Nous observons tous ces événements comme s'ils appartenaient à quelqu'un d'autre, en évitant de s'identifier avec.
De cette façon, nous pouvons les investiguer de manière objective.
Donc, peu importe ce qui arrive, ce qui vient, une sensation, un ressenti, une pensée, il s'agit simplement de les observer avec attention et bienveillance, de les ressentir pleinement, faisant pleinement l'expérience de manière directe.
Donc maintenant, installons-nous et regardons le spectacle avec un vif intérêt.
Observons le flux continu des phénomènes mentaux et physiques.
Commençons toujours par la respiration.
Se lever, se lever, s'abaisser, s'abaisser, toucher, toucher.
Si l'esprit vagabonde, notez ce qu'il est en train de faire.
Rêvez, pensez, se faire du souci, etc. et ramenez-le à la respiration avec douceur et fermeté.
S'il y a de la torpeur ou de la léthargie, de la somnolence, dynamisez la colonne.
Rétablissez la posture.
Faites-le lentement, très lentement, afin de ne pas perturber le calme, la concentration et la tension stable que vous avez développé.
Pour cela, vous pouvez utiliser des mots de notation qui réfèrent au mouvement que vous apprêtez à faire et que vous êtes en train de faire.
Se redresser.
Dans un premier temps, le corps a tendance à être douloureux parce qu'il doit s'habituer à la posture.
Mais il y a parfois aussi de la douleur ou des tensions causées par des émotions non résolues.
ou par des états mentaux qui ont été jusqu'ici réprimés, non écoutés, non accueillis.
Il est important de pouvoir intégrer dans le champ de conscience ces ressentis dans le corps, ces sensations corporelles, de pouvoir se détendre avec ces tensions ou ces douleurs et de développer à leur égard une attitude
intéressée, curieuse, bienveillante.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que cette douleur ?
C'est quoi avoir mal dans le dos ?
C'est quoi avoir des tensions dans les mâchoires ?
Ça se traduit comment ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
De tels inconforts, parfois importants, peuvent durer pendant toute une assise, même plusieurs assises.
jusqu'au moment où ils se résolvent tout seuls d'eux-mêmes par la pratique et l'attention et l'accueil qui leur a enfin été accordé.
Il se peut que la raison sous-jacente à ces douleurs ou à ces tensions soit inconnue.
Mais la disparition de ces tensions ou de ces douleurs dans le corps est le signe que l'émotion qui était à leur origine a disparu, qu'une guérison s'est produite, que ce qui était stocké dans le corps comme ça s'est déstocké.
Nous avons besoin de développer de la patience pour supporter ce genre de choses.
et saisir l'opportunité de voir la douleur en tant que douleur, juste comme une sensation, sans rajouter aucun concept mentaux dessus.
Séparer la douleur physiologique de ce qu'on appelle la souffrance,
qui est plutôt liée à l'aversion ou à la peur, autour de la douleur justement, ou d'autres choses.
Donc on observe les deux dimensions, les sensations douloureuses dans le corps et nos réactions mentales à leur égard.
On note les deux, on investigue les deux, on observe, on ressent et on accueille les deux.
C'est un peu comme si on était au théâtre, à un endroit particulier où on peut voir à la fois la scène et la réaction du public.
Continuez à utiliser des petits mots de notation mentale.
Poursuivez votre investigation.
Continuez à observer, maintenez une attention stable, une attention aiguisée, une curiosité bienveillante.
Qu'est-ce que c'est qui se passe là ?
Si vous vagabondez mentalement, revenez à la respiration.
C'est votre fondation, votre point d'ancrage.
Revenez encore et encore autant que de besoin à la respiration.
En utilisant ce soulever, s'abaisser, toucher.
Si l'esprit vagabonde, ramène-le avec fermeté et douceur à l'objet premier de la méditation, la respiration.
Vous vous sentez somnolent, léthargique ?
Redressez la colonne vertébrale, sans tension.
Continuez à être attentifs aux tensions dans la région des épaules, de la nuque et des mâchoires et de leur envoyer de la détente.
Nous voici maintenant comme assis à l'intérieur de nous-mêmes, en train de regarder notre film intérieur.
Le corps avec ses ressentis et ses sensations.
Le cœur avec ses états d'âme et ses émotions.
Et l'esprit avec ses pensées et ses images.
Tout cela se déploie à sa guise.
Sans contrôle.
Nous n'interférons pas avec.
le processus de révélation se fait naturellement.
Au temps opportun, beaucoup de choses réprimées peuvent émerger de l'inconscient, et elles se révèleront au bon moment, et le bon moment arrive lorsque nous sommes prêts à les accueillir.
à les accepter ces choses difficiles, inconnues jusque-là.
Sous cet angle, la méditation vipassana s'apparente à une psychothérapie.
Même des souvenirs d'enfance douloureux et traumatisants finiront par être éliminés du système.
Et avec eux, tous les problèmes mentaux et physiques et les tensions qu'ils ont causées.
La magie de ce processus, c'est que nous n'avons rien à faire.
Le simple fait de rester fermement établi à notre poste d'observation est suffisant.
Le but de notre pratique ce n'est pas la psychothérapie.
La guérison de notre cœur et de notre esprit est une conséquence naturelle de notre pratique.
Le but de la méditation est d'atteindre des strates plus profondes.
pour voir et comprendre le processus de la souffrance.
Comment la souffrance naît dans mon cœur, dans mon corps et dans mon esprit.
Comment ça se passe ?
J'investigue pour voir cela.
Je regarde ce qui se passe dans le corps pour voir ce processus.
pour se faire une bonne manière de pratiquer et de prendre note et de voir clairement comment nous réagissons à l'agréable et au désagréable.
Comment je veux ce que j'aime et je rejette ce que je n'aime pas.
L'alternance entre je me complais et je rejette.
Cette manière que nous avons de rechercher le bonheur en se complaisant dans l'agréable et en cherchant à supprimer ou à ignorer, à nous débarrasser du désagréable.
Ce constant va-et-vient entre l'avidité et l'aversion est ce que le Bouddha a enseigné comme étant la cause de la souffrance qu'il appelle « deuxième noble vérité ».
À chaque fois que se passe quelque chose d'agréable ou de désagréable, il nous faut noter la réaction de saisie ou de rejet vis-à-vis de ce qui est en train de se passer.
Parfois, nous nous enfuyons de peur.
La peur est la jumelle de l'inversion.
Petit à petit, par la pratique, ces réactions d'aversion et d'avidité se calment et même finissent par s'arrêter.
Et nous faisons l'expérience d'une équanimité profondément satisfaisante, même au cœur des expériences les plus douloureuses.
Et ce faisant, nous pouvons continuer à investiguer toujours plus profondément l'origine de la souffrance.
Alors, laissez toutes ces douleurs et ces plaisirs remonter à la surface, s'exprimer sans les réprimer, sans continuer à les réprimer.
Observez la réaction, la saisie, l'avidité.
L'aversion, la peur est notée.
Désir, désir.
Aversion, aversion.
Peur, peur.
Et toujours, encore et encore, commencer par la respiration.
Se soulever, s'abaisser.
Touché.
Cinquièmement, si votre esprit vagabonde, notez ce qu'il est en train de faire et établissez de nouveau une attention aiguisée sur la respiration.
Vous somnolez, redressez-vous et maintenez l'énergie ou remettez l'énergie le long de la colonne vertébrale.
Au fur et à mesure que vous devenez de plus en plus conscient de tout cela que nous avons évoqué à l'instant, que votre conscience s'approfondit, conscience du corps, de l'esprit et du cœur, vous allez devenir de plus en plus attentif et conscient à ce que le Bouddha appelait les trois caractéristiques de l'existence.
La première est l'impermanence.
La première réalité, c'est celle de l'impermanence, Anidja.
Tout se manifeste et disparaît.
Tout apparaît et disparaît.
Rien ne dure.
Sensation, sentiment, humeur, émotion, pensée, image, etc.
Tout est dans un flux continuel d'apparition et disparition, de début, de durée et de fin.
La deuxième caractéristique plus difficile à saisir est celle du non-soi, anatta.
En observant tous ces phénomènes physiques et mentaux, vous remarquerez qu'ils se manifestent d'eux-mêmes.
Personne ne les contrôle, et pas nous.
Ils vivent par eux-mêmes, ils ont leur propre énergie.
Par moment, il se peut que les sensations et les sentiments physiques et mentaux nous semblent lointains, comme s'ils ne nous appartenaient pas.
Auparavant, nous disions « mes sensations », « ma douleur », « ma colère », « mes pensées », « mes émotions ».
Mais maintenant petit à petit, nous sommes, pour ainsi dire, en mesure de les désigner grâce à la technique des mots de notation.
Il y a une sensation, il y a de la colère, il y a une pensée, il y a un ressenti, il y a une énergie, il y a de la colère, de la peur, de la joie.
De la douleur, il y a.
Et non pas j'ai, je suis.
Je suis en colère.
Je suis joyeux.
Non, il y a de la joie, il y a.
Nous sommes lentement et sûrement en train de nous éloigner d'une relation d'identification et de possession.
dans laquelle nous croyons faussement être ce que nous voyons, ce que nous pensons, ce que nous ressentons.
C'est mon corps, mes sentiments, mes pensées.
Au lieu de cela, nous nous dirigeons vers une position de détachement qui ne s'identifie pas, qui ne possède pas ce dont elle fait l'expérience.
Et cependant, nous expérimentons tout.
Troisième caractéristique.
Comme nous l'avons remarqué, à chaque fois que nous tombons dans une relation basée sur l'identification et la possession, le désir ou l'aversion apparaissent.
Nous luttons alors contre les choses telles qu'elles sont.
Nous voulons qu'elles soient différentes.
Plus comme ci, moins comme ça.
Ça, c'est la troisième caractéristique de l'existence, celle de l'insatisfaction.
D'où le cas.
L'attitude à développer par rapport au corps, à l'esprit et au cœur est celle d'une personne locataire et non pas d'un propriétaire.
L'observation de ces trois caractéristiques, anidja, anatta et dukkha, impermanence, non-soi et insatisfaction,
nous permet d'accéder à des visions spirituelles profondes qui libèrent notre intelligence intuitive de l'illusion dans laquelle elle était jusqu'à présent et nous conduit vers la libération de toute souffrance.
Notre outil pour cela est la pratique de vipassana.
Cette attention pure, simplement regarder tout ce qui apparaît et disparaît.
Cette présence sans choix, qui ne contrôle pas, ne manipule pas.
Cette observation impartiale, qui ne juge pas, ne conteste pas.
Cette introspection intuitive, expérimentant pleinement chaque phénomène mental, corporel ou du cœur tel qu'il est vraiment, ça c'est Satipaṁyā, la faculté d'intelligence intuitive.
Faculté même qui finira par se réaliser dans le nirvāṇa.
L'inconditionné, ce qui n'est pas né, ce qui n'est pas créé, ne meurt pas.
Tout ce que nous avons à faire, c'est juste regarder, ressentir et expérimenter tout ce qui apparaît et disparaît.
Ayons foi, ayons confiance.
Au fond de nous se trouve cette intelligence intuitive.
Une fois libérée de la confusion mentale et émotionnelle, notre intelligence intuitive a le pouvoir de comprendre, de prendre avec elle, d'accueillir,
Et de voir les causes de la souffrance et de l'insatisfaction.
Et de nous conduire vers un état de contentement et de bonheur permanent.
Nous recommençons avec la respiration.
Se lever, s'abaisser, toucher.
Donc dernière petite partie.
Dans la vie quotidienne, s'asseoir ainsi même juste quelques instants.
Assez longtemps pour réétablir une attention calme et alerte.
Après chaque action, empêche nos émotions de faire bout de neige.
Diminue le stress.
Quinze secondes seulement peuvent suffire à nous recentrer.
Avec la pratique, cela peut devenir et cela devient un état d'esprit ordinaire, réflexe, au lieu de quelque chose qui se manifeste uniquement dans des conditions particulières.
Un cœur paisible et un esprit alerte.
sont l'état que nous pouvons connaître à tout moment, même dans des situations très difficiles, quand nous les avons entraînés suffisamment par la pratique.
Au sein de cet environnement intérieur, l'intelligence intuitive Satipañña peut œuvrer.
Sans cet environnement stable et calme qui voit et accueille tout ce qui est, cette hypaniale intelligence intuitive est perdue, noyée et contrôlée par un flot de pensées et d'émotions incessants.
C'est pourquoi nous avons intérêt à constamment faire et refaire encore l'effort
de retrouver et maintenir cette posture intérieure que nous avons évoquée et développée dans cette pratique à l'instant.
En fait, cela signifie vivre pleinement, pleinement conscient, vivre, être et non pas avoir.
De cette manière, la pratique de vipassana, la méditation de la vision intérieure, s'infiltre dans chaque moment de notre vie.
Et nous en retirons de grands bénéfices.
Lorsque vous arrivez à la fin d'une période de méditation, comme ça va être le cas dans quelques instants,
N'en sortez pas brusquement, mais lentement.
Ne vous levez pas précipitamment, dès que la cloche sonne.
Quand la cloche sonne, on l'écoute jusqu'au bout.
Début, durée du son, fin du son.
Commencez par ouvrir les yeux, en laissant la lumière pénétrer.
Puis, balancez-vous d'un côté de l'autre
Ayez l'intention de vous lever, et dites-le vous, et levez-vous lentement et consciemment, de sorte à maintenir la stabilité de l'attention et votre capacité d'intelligence intuitive satipagna, qu'elle soit là.
Mais avant de faire cela, avant de terminer, il est important de transformer la sagesse que nous avons pu obtenir pendant l'assise en une attitude d'amour bienveillant.
Pour cela, nous le faisons avec la pratique de Metta, la bonté bienveillante, l'amour bienveillant, la gentillesse aimante, la bienveillance.
Il est important de terminer chaque assise avec 5 à 10 minutes de
de pratique de Méta.
Puissez-vous être en sécurité, que vous soyez en bonne santé, que vous soyez heureux, que vous viviez dans le contentement et dans l'harmonie avec le monde
les autres et vous-même.
Que vous soyez bientôt libérés de toutes les souffrances.
Que vous fassiez l'expérience de la paix et des délices et de la béatitude du nirvana.
Que vous soyez heureux et en paix, libres de toute souffrance.
Que votre cœur soit confiant, joyeux et ouvert.
Que vous soyez libres de toute souffrance.
Que vous soyez heureux et en paix.
Que vous viviez dans le contentement et en harmonie avec vous-mêmes, les autres et le monde.
Que je sois en sécurité.
Que je sois en bonne santé.
Que je sois heureux.
Que je vive dans le contentement et en harmonie avec le monde, les autres et moi-même.
Que je sois bientôt libéré de toute souffrance.
Que je fasse l'expérience de la paix et des bienfaits et des délices et de la béatitude du nirvana.